bing bong there's gorilla nems check me
out on the bootleg kev podcast stupid
[ __ ] your life
bullet cap podcast special guest coney
island's finest in here yo yo yo [ __ ]
your life bing bong [ __ ] your life man
shout out to my guy names it's good to
see you man likewise bro been a few
years i know and you know we got through
the pandemic absolutely you've been
super active likewise uh and uh
yeah you had an interesting rap show
last night with it was brother ali
immortal technique
yourself yeah who am i missing
supernatural was there supernatural
supernatural when i was a kid the first
time i saw supernat i freaked out when i
was it he was like grabbing people's ids
out of the crowd and [ __ ] and like
freestyling their name and it was fun
and then he would like twirl around and
then come back as like another rapper's
voice yo did he do that last night no
he's not not to my knowledge but yo it's
like
when i first started battling he was the
host of these things and he doesn't look
any like not a day older than back then
i i grew older he didn't yeah he used to
and then and then i thought he was like
you know super nat
was like in the backpack circuit he was
like yeah every tour yes but then they
put him on a lincoln park hybrid theory
tour did that and he hosted the lincoln
park [ __ ] it might have been the
reanimation it was one of those leaking
parts yeah yeah and i was like super
nasty about to cross over yeah that's
crazy shout out supernatural super not
the legend man yep uh so what's up man
what what have you been up to other than
obviously putting out a [ __ ] ton of
music selling a [ __ ] ton of merch uh you
know [ __ ] on a [ __ ] ton of smokers
in your neighborhood that's right don't
you ever disrespect yeah we're working
on a comedy tour i'm gonna i'm bringing
gorilla weekend to every city yo
remember where you heard it first
because i know well rappers ain't doing
comedy i'm gonna make it one night i do
a rap show the next night i do a comedy
show the third night i do a pop-up every
city's gonna have a gorilla weekend like
when i release congo in august i had
this thing called gorilla weekend
because everything was shut down during
the pandemics right i said you know what
i'm gonna [ __ ] shut down my block in
coney island put barricades up and i
didn't get no permits nothing i'm gonna
have a flatbed truck pull up i'm gonna
make that the stage and i'm gonna
[ __ ] perform joints with the album
since we can't really get a venue right
now wow so i did that sold the merch and
that was called gorilla day and then uh
now we're gonna throw gorilla days in
every city any possible we're working on
that right now are you fine or anything
for me nope i'm the mayor coney island
man this is true even the cops know the
cops buy merch from me people be yo
names i got arrested by this [ __ ]
undercover wearing your hat
i was like [ __ ] on [ __ ] your life wow
the undercovers are wearing them
everybody everybody wears this [ __ ] man
hey it's crazy like coney island um
outside of yourself like i really can't
think of like an artist that you could
maybe educate me who was like another
artist from coney island um toray
toray who's now doing radio yes he was
on uh duck down for a while yep yeah
okay i didn't know you from coney island
there's not really that many because
that's why i rep it so hard man and when
i when i used to deal with rigs morales
had shady records i used to run up over
there he was like yo names one of the
best things you got going for you is
you're from you're from brooklyn but
you're from a neighborhood in brooklyn
that nobody ever blew up out of yet so
you got here and and even before that
i always everybody knows of coney island
they think of the rides i just think of
the rides yeah yeah of course but when
there's the rides that's where stephon
marbury's from right yeah stefan mall
back that's what i always think of when
i think of coney island i think it's
stefan mulberry's tattoo yeah yeah
there's stefan mulberry sebastian
telfair and uh uh lance stephenson shout
out to lance says shabashan but he paid
he's facing some fed charges right on
the other i was with him two nights ago
is he okay he's great he's doing great i
saw all those names i was like oh baby
davis dave yeah i know y'all
yo i was like [ __ ] insurance fraud no i
i was like yo bad he was like yo
he's like yo minus set back for a major
comeback
and my whole life i've known him he's
done nothing but he played for my sons
for like one season yeah yeah yeah he
played for probably every team in the
nba he might have
but you know he's uh he's one of my my
closest friends he's he's one of my good
friends and uh
he's gonna get through it man just you
know
we were talking um you were saying how
you know previously in your music you
used to say the n word yeah for people
who don't know
what is your racial makeup i'm puerto
rican and i'm irish um
my father who was irish passed away when
i was four okay i'm saying i've been
around but
i'm i'm in new york
that's that's how just people talk in
general like even the white guy said the
asian people right you know when you
grow up around in new york there's no
neighborhoods there's just one race
mm-hmm you live next door to a very very
very next door to somebody from pakistan
and your next neighbors from from
the age from from from china your next
door other neighbor might be dominican
right right right right right oh it's
like a melting pot you know what i'm
saying and and and growing up
it was never even known that it was a
racial thing that just became part of
our vernacular how we speak to each
other um and just growing up
it was never a problem so i started
doing tours and going to other cities
besides new york and then i would see
people how they would react to me saying
it because
when you look at me you might see
different people see different things
people see me seeing puerto ricans some
people see me some people think i'm
russian some people think that yeah some
people think i'm i'm i'm arab i'm
totally like yo if you told me you were
like you know if i came through with
that
yeah you know armenian or something yeah
like yep absolutely so depends on what
you see but if you look at me and see
i'm white
then you would have a problem saying it
and and
you know i'm not going to go in and tell
everybody you know i'm from the heart
i'm not nah it's just if you don't like
it say something nobody never said
nothing to me a person but as a man and
just what
i don't want to give people a shot of
not liking me before they even hear me
and more importantly than that
i don't want to make any i'm out of asia
and i'm growing up and being become more
mature with myself that i don't want to
say anything to somebody that's going to
offend them you know you don't have to
when i don't have to like why i start
off like
how when i grew up i was had to be tough
and all that but as i grow up man i'd
rather laugh with you than joke with you
i'd rather talk about our similarities
than our differences and and just the
climate that the world is at right now i
just was like yo i'm cutting this off
out of my music in my last album congo
is that your first album where you guys
that's my first album where
i didn't use the word because i'm i'm
maturing as a man but also as an artist
and um
that just is there's no for me
personally i don't have to say it i'm i
have a a a vocabulary where i don't have
to say it right i'm saying i could i
could kill verses and kill bars
without having that in my music and like
boom it's done that's though man yeah
talk to me about uh bing bong and like
how the knicks remix came to be and
the bing bong stuff is um
you're a knicks fan obviously despite
being from brooklyn you you weren't one
of these people who jumped ship to the
nets because a lot there's a lot of
those yeah i'm a lifelong knicks fan but
i'm also if if the nets go to the
playoffs i'm rooting for them because
i'm brooklyn all the way even though
they're really the jersey right right
listen they're brooklyn now they got
brooklyn in their name if they win i'm
gonna root for them of course um
but i'm a knicks fan and uh
the nick's been [ __ ]
forever for the longest yeah so if i
could if i created something that's
making this them get hyped and maybe
possibly put the battery in their back
to win some games i love it but i just
started off saying it like messing
around bing bong you know like yeah you
know you say yo you know i just body
this verse bomb you know and then i just
bing bong just playing around i would
throw it on my stories on instagram bing
bong showing my merch and then it just
took off i started putting on t's and
hats he started selling and um
and then i started the side talk people
the side talk kids that's the popular
instagram page popping they would have
me in their video they'd come to coney
island i'm saying it bing bong bing bong
and then it just took off from there and
then the knicks
just took off with it and just was a
certain player that like [ __ ] nah
what happened is that um they was in
front of the knicks opening night and
the knicks had one everybody in this oh
they were losing their [ __ ] mind yeah
they're going crazy somebody said bing
bong from seeing me saying it all the
time and uh and the next just ran with
it took it all the knicks fans just ran
with it and then now i'm starting i'm
doing all types of sports talk radios
those type of crap carton and robbers
they're showing me love they're bringing
me up there i'm like yo this is a whole
new
fan base in genre just right now in the
airport come here at least three to four
guys that i know don't even listen to
rap right right came up to me and yo
you're the bing bong guy and last night
at the show somebody's kid was he was
like yo my son their basketball team
loves the bing book cause you sent me a
video of my my kill no problem man
i spent years doing
um
bringing negativity into the world you
know doing the wrong thing growing up i
did jail time i was doing robberies
right do all types of stuff so it's it's
a good chance to switch it up man and
bring some positive stuff into the into
the atmosphere now
do you feel like without the comma i was
going to say do you feel like uh just
[ __ ] because you've always been so nice
man but i always feel like i don't know
maybe it was the n-word thing i always
just felt like what is the thing that's
not like sign holding me back yeah like
do you feel like you're fired like
things are finally lining up for you
absolutely because also
um
growing up as an artist like i really
live this [ __ ] life [ __ ] like yo i
don't i don't want to i'm not a small
talker i'm not a good networker i'm not
going to approach you and tell you y'all
you know how you doing now if i don't
know you i don't want to talk to you i'm
a i'm a close i'm a loner i like to you
know what my squad head but i'm a loner
at the end of the day i don't mind being
alone i don't i don't like talking a lot
so i'm six foot four 300 pounds people
sometimes get intimidated by that they
don't want to say nothing
and i also move everything that i've
gained done with the merch with the
music i did on my own there's no team
there's no management there's no label i
was doing that all on my own and uh
you get a perception if you just listen
to my music you think i'm an ignorant
hennis god type of guy right but now
when i do i hate doing podcasts but i do
like people i [ __ ] with i [ __ ] issue
yeah i do certain ones um like premium
pete my man i'm saying like and once
people the story of me like i tell my
story
because i've been at the bottom for a
long time like even before like i was
doing robbery i didn't want to do
robberies it just i i was [ __ ] up man
i was sleeping in staircases i was at
the bottom in life and um once i told my
story like if you really knew what i
went through people would have no
problem with me winning because i was at
the bottom bottom and um i think as my
people see me as a person more um
they relate to it you know what i'm
saying that's the same thing dmx why did
we love dmx yeah we related to him
because dmx didn't hold no punches he
kept it real with who he was yeah and
when you do that when you're humble and
the humble will never be humiliated you
know what i'm saying when you just put
all your [ __ ] out on front street this
is me
taking the love of the lead right
people respect that brother even if they
don't like it they respect it and that's
what i throw into my music and that's
why people uh my music is getting better
and better because people
you know i throw songs on that emotion i
tell my story like and and and people
[ __ ] with it i mean the [ __ ] that's what
i always tell people you could be
relatable
and the music
being relatable to people and if the
music and the talent you put those two
things together absolutely like yo if
you're a broke rapper i'm about being
broke man struggling if you live with
your mom yo i live with my mom i'm
trying to get the [ __ ] out of here if
you keep it real like i got a little
cousin that raps and i tell him like he
always talking about shooting then
you grow up with both parents in a nice
house like yeah i'm saying what's your
thing you like smoking weed and hanging
out with girls right well i'm about that
just be yourself wear this luck they see
in the 90s and the earth you're at the
front you know i'm the hardest rapper
it's hard to front now because of social
media exactly everybody's the whole
world is transitioning everybody yo just
be yourself don't take yourself too
seriously nobody else does yo i feel
like if you were in the 90s it would
have been over for you would have been
out of here oh forget what forget about
it what
hey um you so you talking about doing
like like some time uh what what what
were the reasons why you like first of
all what was the longest bid you did i
did a one and a half to four and a half
year bid for robbery in the third degree
what year was that this was in 0
6.
and what did you end up i wound up i'm
only doing like 13 months because i did
the first first uh first time felon
program the shock program right where
it's like a boot camp type of thing
because when i was doing the whole fight
club [ __ ] battling mm-hmm i was on the
run i caught the case that i got locked
up for eventually i caught i was i did
it oh three wow i did a robbery i got
caught and uh i got bailed out and just
was like well i'm not turning myself
back and [ __ ] that and uh i started
doing the fight club i kept winning i'm
all over mtv [ __ ] is popping and then i
get caught yeah the judge was like yo
boom more than half the phone but she
said since you stayed out of trouble for
four years i'm gonna drop this to
non-violent wow so if it was if you got
rewarded for being on the run
if uh if it would have stayed a violent
felony then i wouldn't have been able to
get that first time felon program but
because she dropped it to non-violent
the one if you have nine years of under
they give you the chance yo you're a
first-time felon you do this this shock
boot camp type [ __ ] it's still jail but
it's like a boot camp you wake up 5 a.m
you got to run work out
um and i was like i didn't want to do it
but i was like yo my career is just
starting to take off now with the
balance all over mtv every single night
i was like let me give it a chance if it
works out it works out if not so i ended
up doing altogether 14 months
came home on parole
stayed you know grabbed the wizonator i
had the wizonator at the time with the
fake piss
and uh that [ __ ] works huh absolutely it
was it was fake pissed or like a fake
dick that you it's a fake dick okay see
when i came home my guy just had got off
a fed parole okay and he was like yo hey
i don't need this no more take it
gave you his fake dick he gave me the
fake wizard but the thing was
he was a couple shades darker than me oh
so you gotta you you get the dick you
buy the one that matches your skin yeah
so if the wizonator is a is a plastic
it's like a dildo but it comes with a
powder you got to strap it around you
and on the pouch like that goes along
your waist
is you put clean urine into it
and when you go to parole it's like
you're pulling out your dick because
they're looking at you they stand behind
you and the mirrors on the opposite side
so they're looking into the mirror but
on the bottom of the the fake dick is a
button and the clean piss comes out of
it and it stays against your body so it
keeps the same body temperature so it
comes out warm right right right so um
my man that gave it to me is like a
little bit darker than me so the [ __ ]
was a little bit darker i don't i don't
know how i got away with it but one time
they didn't take my piss for like three
months
uh me stupid i kept the same pissing now
i didn't change it like whatever
so i went to parole he asked for the
urine i pressed the button
[ __ ] came out like applesauce oh i was
like oh [ __ ] he said yo
you tested it put the little strip in it
he said yo
it's clean but i need you to go straight
to the hospital when you get the [ __ ]
out of there because something's not
right i was like sorry sir i just don't
drink a lot of water i'm going straight
to the hospital whatever the case yeah
i'm saying
and that he let me go and i was like
thank god empty that [ __ ] out put some
forgot some clean put it in there but
you know that [ __ ] was crazy even me i
was like what the [ __ ] is yeah yeah wait
so you you came out lumpy you said this
it was hard like he was like sir
you got cancer yeah
you got something going on with your
black you should have an sdd go to the
hospital
you're clean but yeah this guy had
frozen pain
he said it came out lumpy yeah that was
horrible it's funny you look back on
time like that man this was it
it was uh but i don't even remember i
was taking piss from anybody
would you pay people for their business
yeah hell yeah yeah yo i got 50 to take
a piss in this [ __ ] bottle for me
that's great and it comes with like a
syringe you take it out the [ __ ] cup
or whatever and then you put it into the
[ __ ] wizard there that [ __ ] was a
[ __ ] hassle you know it would be
easier if i just didn't do anything
well now you're not you don't need
anything so now you were telling me all
you do is go with this [ __ ] vape [ __ ]
man i gotta
that's tobacco not a tobacco yeah yeah
wait hold on time to stop the interview
because we got to talk about our good
folks at odd socks man listen if you go
to
oddssoxofficial.com that's
oddsoxofficial.com
use the keyword keyword it's a [ __ ]
promo code use the [ __ ] promo code
bootleg kev all right at checkout you'll
save 20 off they got i mean look at
these spongebob joints
man the ninja turtle boys you know what
i'm saying how about the naruto guys and
then they got the new odd socks basics
that are just like
they're just so fly man the tie-dye
joints they just listen man
whatever you need they got it how about
some half-baked boys you know what i'm
saying
listen the most comfortable socks the
most affordable socks the best socks in
the world odd socks so go to
oddssocksofficial.com
use that keyword it's not a keyword it's
a [ __ ] promo code
[ __ ]
bootleg cab at checkout save twenty
percent off man shout out to our family
at odd socks if you support us go
support them yes
at everything i did man like cigarettes
have been the [ __ ] hardest but just
vape [ __ ] you are smoking on the plane
you know chill out
do you smoke it on the floor yeah
[ __ ] put it in my hoodie yo
like a real [ __ ] feeling what was
like uh was weed something that you
was just like everything i was doing
i didn't smoke crack and i didn't shoot
needles everything about and meth is not
really on the east coast but everything
else you was participating yeah yeah
yeah i was sniffing dope like
like like sniffing coke taking xanax
before it was possible did you sniff
heroin yeah yeah yeah oh [ __ ] four four
wow yeah that brought me to the bottom
man i was like i never shot no needles
though like and i never so that was my
thing in my head like i'm not shooting
needles i'm good you know what i'm
saying oh heroine's like this that's
some serious [ __ ] to get off so it was
crazy bro how long were you doing heroin
probably like eight years wow and i did
the whole thing the fight club [ __ ] all
of that [ __ ] was was [ __ ] up so you
were yo listen i would go i remember i
went on a specific trip to detroit to
battle with proof and all of that
i don't remember anything that happened
on the trip i don't
if it wasn't recorded i wouldn't even
know i went there wow when i first met
alchemist i was like yo al nice to meet
you he was like
i've been [ __ ] with you since we met
in detroit i was like damn i don't even
remember that wow i don't remember
meeting one of my favorite producers
ras cash same thing he was out there
detroit judging the battle and he was
like yo i mentioned [ __ ] detroit like
well i don't i don't even remember i
wasn't even knowing i was out there i
mean eight years is a long time yeah
because it wasn't just that it was that
coke
and the xanax just make you forget
everything like so by the end of the run
i was on
everything i was on probably about two
bundles of dope a day
five twenties of coke and about
five xanax every single day
it wasn't like i was working you know
i'm saying i would wake up every day
like y'all got to go out and get this
money however means necessary robin you
know what i'm saying do you think you
were working to keep your drug drug
absolutely i had a [ __ ] three 400 a
day habit with no job nothing that's
what people always say if you have an
addiction i'm sure like you probably
applied to a sex addiction too like if
you have any sort of addiction like
you got to work on yourself
the work ethic to get high every day
right it's like yeah like imagine if
like most people who had that work ethic
to get high every day and still be semi
like
exactly they applied it to literally
anything else that's what i'm doing now
you never did you ever smoke crack no no
no no never um i just i've always i want
to know what crack feels like
i watch i watch
i watch that [ __ ] franklin safe when his
girlfriend oh yeah yeah yeah but she was
hitting the crack pipe in the show i
said [ __ ]
look like it's fire but yeah now i'm at
the point where i've been clean for over
12 years already big man it's longer
than what i was [ __ ] up with you know
what i'm saying what was like for you
the breaking point where you were like i
gotta get the [ __ ]
take care of this [ __ ] man i had um like
the fight club stuff was going on i had
a development deal with shady records
there was like your names you love your
music
like
but you're going in and out of jail
because i would do besides the the main
[ __ ] i would do like little skid bids
like i would go to rikers for two weeks
so rikers for a month come out yo you're
going in and out of jail we take you to
places sometimes you don't show up when
you do show up you [ __ ] you run
outside you rob people outside the
studio you're doing like i was just like
living crazy like wow yeah yeah this is
you never had any uh instances where you
thought you might have overdosed or
gotten close to it that's a lot of drugs
like this
back then there wasn't like the fentanyl
[ __ ] now like you know what i'm saying
it was it was different and i never oh
when i dealt with people i dealt with
people i knew that i grew up with from
coney island i'm saying like and there
wasn't like
luckily i didn't have to go through none
of that was that getting off of the [ __ ]
hard going through withdrawals it was
but the last year two of my of my my
addiction i was like yo i didn't want to
do it it was just more like a job it was
like yo if i'm ever able to stop doing
this for a couple days when i'm not sick
anymore like i'm never gonna do this
again i'm so tired of living this
lifestyle but i also had given up on my
dreams with the rap [ __ ] like i i didn't
want i didn't care about nothing but
getting high like and then it just had
like a moment of clarity one day
i was on like a three week run like i
hadn't slept i hadn't
showered none of that and i was like had
like a i don't know if it was psychosis
or like i had a body experience i was
like i could keep going how i'm going
right now
and i'm going to be dead or i'm going to
be in jail the rest of my life from
doing something stupid
or i could just stop right now and live
my dreams
like like i had already given up on my
dreams and that night
i went to my mother's house she was
living in staten island i was in coney
island at the time i was like yo mom
please let me just stay at your house
she was like nah you can't she been not
letting me right she knew you were yeah
yeah she was but something she let me
stay and uh i just kept the wheels going
i stopped one day
two i had to go through it and when i
got through it though
i never touched nothing again nothing no
not a drink not weed nothing
so you've been totally sober for 12
years nothing nothing wow that's best
that's real big man yeah yeah yeah and
and the evidence is there since i
stopped that my whole [ __ ] life is
you know like i bought my mom's a house
got me a house i got [ __ ] right now
they're putting us in ground salt water
pool in my backyard right now they're
doing it as we speak and
and uh you're still in coney island no
no no i bought a house of staten island
okay which is like 20 minutes
um it's close enough that when i want to
hang out
and be a be you know be a whole bugger
do hood stuff with my hood friends you
know what i'm saying like yeah we we can
move over there and um and when i want
to be left alone
go to the crib and go to the crib that's
it
um
you i didn't know you had a
developmental deal with shady yeah yeah
i was dealing with rigs rigs morales man
so that's my god was that who kind of
found you yeah he because he was the he
was he started the fight club nobody
really knows that he started the fight
club and so he was heavily involved with
it so he would see he had like a front
row seat too yeah yeah yeah how you got
down absolutely he
got still talking rigs to this day man
he's always he's always shown love and
been in my corner even like you know
without
do you ever have any any any
uh
experienced like me and am or
m i didn't meet um the rest of d12
[ __ ] with heavy
detroit on the regular bazaar would take
fly meow [ __ ] proof will fly me out
rest in peace all in a mcvay swifty
they they all us i i still talk with
swifty mcv uh and conniver can i have
you know what i'm saying like i [ __ ]
with them heavy like um
but i never met him they're always like
yo em is like
he's he's
included you know what i'm saying yeah
it's crazy he's like one of the only
rappers that like made it and just
didn't leave yeah yeah yeah but like
also feels like untouchable in the sense
because you would think like if you're
that big out of detroit you won't get
the [ __ ] out of the truth actually he
stayed in fact and like nobody i do know
in detroit for me the limited times i'm
out there i don't know there's pilots
that's a street pilot but i do know like
a lot of people know each other mostly
people know each other and trick trick
is really that guy out there for sure
for sure i'm saying that yeah the choice
got a crazy scene right now edmond trick
is close what i'm saying so he's like
you know i'm good yeah yeah
um you fat joe just showed you some love
yeah they asked them you know we cracked
who who what they asked him that's
pretty much who is like today's fat joe
but they asked him a whole array of a
bunch of different y'all who's the new
team
yeah that that and they asked me oh is
that a new fat joe and he said
yeah this is a new fat joe his name is
nems out of coney island i was like yeah
that's crazy do you you and joe got a
relationship yeah joe uh
i mean we're not super close i've hung
out with them on different occasions
like we've gone to shows and through my
main ufo feed my man ufo feed really
made the introduction
and um
and me and phoebe was doing a lot does
do a lot of music and when he made the
introduction with with joe crack i call
him crack you know what i'm saying um
but um when he made the introduction
crack crack just showed me love
automatically and then for me being
around him more and he's seeing how a
movie follows me you know he's we speak
through the dms and and even his team
like uncle dan and a couple they they
[ __ ] with me they show me mad love so i
guess from just from him observing and
watching and he you know he's he had
told me that before he said it on the tv
that you buy your names you remind me of
me when i was younger man a couple times
he told me that but for him to say it on
rap city's first episode yeah the first
one i didn't even know he was doing that
my phone just started blowing up like yo
fat joe just said that look i said yo uh
that's i think one of the only times in
my
throughout this rapture that i actually
like
almost i didn't i didn't cry but i
almost shed a tear out of just
pure
i grew up listening to the fat joe big
pun's my favorite especially being a
puerto rican from new york like they
held it down like especially in my era
went out it was them guys yeah um so
when he said that it was more like
validation like from all this hard work
because me
i'm my own worst critic i still grind
every day like i'm
like not like i'm still like nobody
knows me right right you know what i'm
saying i look at it like bro
i have not reached where i want to be in
this music stuff
so i still act like nobody knows me and
i got to make an impression every single
time and i got to put in the work every
single day to live my dreams to the
extent that i want to live it so when he
said that
it was like validation like yo
somebody's out there watching yeah
especially somebody who you looked up to
especially a hundred percent like and
you know i got a little watery i ain't
shed a tear you know i'm shame
over here but like it was it was like it
was one of the the best moments of my
career man what's next for you um are
you going to keep just kind of keep keep
your foot on the gas with dropping music
well next is me and scram jones shout
out to the dragon the album that [ __ ] is
ridiculous um it's just stupid hard just
i think he's one of those slept on
producers yeah yeah he's a great guy too
yeah um i knew scram since he was there
from the beginning like when i first
started writing when he was rapping
scram is nest yeah a lot of people don't
know right and one of the things that's
holding up the album is like scram we
got to get a joint me and you uh i'm not
i'm writing mo i'm like screaming let's
go bro put the [ __ ] verse on the [ __ ]
let's go
but um he's nicer than a lot of mc's
that i know for sure um but his beats
are crazy that's the next project after
that probably me a static selector nice
shout out to static and uh and then
we're just taking it from there there it
is man man listen congo's out out right
now [ __ ] your life [ __ ] your life uh
is there any any
let me ask you this because since the
pandemic started i feel like
i always say this like i feel like it
helped
with
the bars
in terms of
fans
wanting that or wanting more substance
or wanting more from music because
[ __ ] weren't in the club
standing on couches popping bottles so
you saw
benny and wes saigon and freddie gibbs
all these people have the best years of
their career royce the five nine was
nominated for a grammy you know what i'm
saying like do you feel like that the
pandemic helped kind of like correct
the path that hip-hop was on because it
feels like absolutely man absolutely
that's
listen everything has a cycle facts you
know so it was already gearing back
towards the lyric driven music and the
stuff that i'm sure me and you grew up
listening to um
but the pandemic pushed it forward like
a little like made it
rapidly and speed up the process yeah
and um it's great great timing for you
man i never stopped doing this i mean
even when people were snapping their
fingers bouncing i was always doing this
type of music man and the people know
that and and
and they respect me the transparency and
when you [ __ ] continuously do
something no matter what if you show
consistency and just keep at it
something's going to happen out of it in
a positive manner
where can people buy merch find your
[ __ ] because you got so much you drop
merch every time
nyc because if you got a dot com you
[ __ ] you know what i'm saying so fyl
dot nyc yeah go buy a hat go buy a phone
buy some more stop being a cheap [ __ ]
your whole life that's why your girl
hates you go buy a godzilla's [ __ ]
shirt yeah facts